let's get to it though with ben
roethlisberger
and let me set the stage here myles
because it was a few weeks ago
that we heard from steelers owner art
rooney saying
essentially we want to do it again
but we have to do something about his
contract 41.25 million dollar cap charge
going into the last year of his deal we
have to do something ben roethlisberger
quickly says hey i'm up for it i want to
come back i don't even care what i make
this year so it created the impression
this would easily get fixed
and like everything else that seems easy
this one isn't easy here's gm kevin
colbert speaking to reporters yesterday
about roethlisberger's situation
yeah as we sit here today ben is a
member of the pittsburgh steelers uh he
met with art rooney he went with coach
tomlin he met with myself
uh shortly after the season ended
he reiterated that to us that he wants
to continue to play
and we we told him quite frankly we have
to look at this current situation you
know art rooney addressed that that with
ben's current uh cap number um some
adjustment will have to be made and
we're not negotiating as we sit here and
answer this question you know ben
roethlisberger is on the team ben
roethlisberger did a lot of really good
things
last year and we anticipate that he
could still do some good things moving
forward so hopefully there's a way that
we can try to figure out and do what's
best
for the organization and do what's best
for ben and hopefully
he'll be able to see that and feel the
same way we do but there's a lot of work
that needs to be done it is first and
foremost financially because we have to
be in compliance and then we're making
estimates on as to what we can do to put
the best team together um
for our sake for ben's sake what kind of
team can he
anticipate being around
him if if we decide that we can move
forward together
so it's a ongoing process that this
doesn't involve him but it involves the
players around him and i'm sure he's
going to want to see what type of team
we can keep together under our current
situations and hopefully we can all make
the correct adjustments
to keep that group together as much as
possible
piercing through what we just heard
miles this is my gut feeling the
steelers if they believe
are not going to have enough talent
around ben roethlisberger to be true
contenders in 2021 they are just going
to remove the band-aid and end it with
ben that's the question here because it
should not be difficult to figure out a
contract it should not be all that hard
to move the cap number somewhere between
41.25 and 22.25 and he's counting for
22.25 no matter what but the steelers
understand i believe that if they're not
going to be very good let's go ahead and
be not very good all the way and start
planning for our future at the
quarterback position
yeah i sort of got deja vu listening to
colbert talk from a couple of weeks ago
when we were listening to les snead and
he said well jared goff is a ram right
now at this moment uh what's today it's
january whatever it is and derek goff is
a ram right now and if kevin colbert's
gonna talk about ben roethlisberger in
those same sort of terms then it just
makes you think well
they seem to be planning to move on
without him and i think that kind of
that makes sense now i also agree that
roethlisberger did some good things in
2020 but i think when it came to the end
of the season you're like man i don't
know how much more he's got in the tank
and if that is the case then mike i
totally understand why they're starting
to think about their future without ben
roethlisberger and frankly if he can't
come back or if he doesn't agree to come
back at a significantly reduced rate
then yeah i think mike it would make a
lot of sense for them to start to move
on from him
i mean think about this they have a
meeting right after the season he says
i'm all in and they say whoa
whoa
we have to take a look at your situation
that's not good from the get-go and what
culvert said yesterday does conflict to
a certain extent with the message sent
by art rooney now it could be that art
rooney just doesn't want to be the bad
cop in all of this and anytime you have
separation with a quarterback who has
been a cornerstone of your franchise
since 2004 when he was thrust into
action tommy maddox gets injured here
comes ben roethlisberger i still recall
vividly allen fanuc a new hall of famer
saying i really don't want to play with
this guy fresh out of college they go
1501 and they almost get to the super
bowl and they win it the next year and
then they win it three years after that
and it's not going to be an easy thing a
lot of steelers fans out there even
though 10 years ago they were ready to
move on without ben roethlisberger after
the off-field stuff they are loyal to
ben and they don't like the idea of
conceding and if you don't move forward
with ben and if you don't have somebody
else that you can easily bring in and
given their cap situation they probably
don't it's mason rudolph or dwayne
haskins and if i'm a steelers fan i'm
not thrilled about 2021 but you could be
better in 2022
if you go ahead and move on from ben in
2021 i think that's what they're
thinking
yeah and i i wouldn't feel really good
about having dwayne haskins or mason
rudolph as my quarterback either i mean
maybe a little bit better with rudolph
over haskins but at the same time look
that's not that's not a good qb
situation that you're walking into there
especially when you think about how
awful they were at running the ball
especially down the stretch in the
season they couldn't run the ball at all
and i think that almost has more to do
with why ben roethlisberger started to
look as bad as he did toward the end
there especially in that playoff game
against cleveland look things just
weren't going right when they did not
have any kind of run game and so that
first of all is the thing that they've
got to correct and if they don't correct
that run game problem then i don't
necessarily know how good ben
roethlisberger is going to be anyway
because really the best way i think to
extend the life of an aging quarterback
is to have a solid run game and when the
steelers didn't have that you obviously
saw mike that they just couldn't get
anything done to win football games
look at that rushing yards per game 84.4
dead last in the nfl and miles you said
couldn't run the ball there's a belief
that with roethlisberger at the line of
scrimmage and having the power to change
plays they wouldn't run the ball
specifically he wouldn't run the ball
checking into pass plays instead and if
that's going on and if that's
aggravating the coaching staff and if
they feel like they just can't tell him
what to do and at this point of his
career he's not coachable to some extent
to some extent i don't want to paint too
broadly here but if there's any type of
irritation that is lingering because of
that that's when you have a head coach
who says we just can't behave this way
we can't operate this way we need a
quarterback who's going to do what we
expect him to do and he can't change all
our running plays to pass plays and
that's part of the problem now as it
relates to the contract
when i listened to colbert
as we played it earlier in the segment
he makes it sound a lot more complicated
than it is it's really not complicated
and there's an easy way to fix this now
there's two ways it goes one is he gets
his full 19 million this year and they
restructure it so it becomes a signing
bonus
the most that you can you have to leave
1.075 million behind his salary that's
the minimum salary he can be paid this
year but then the rest of that money can
be turned into a signing bonus and you
can shrink the rest of the number this
year you can get around 26 million but
then you have to
take the difference next you're always
going to have that reckoning see there's
all when you have a quarterback and you
have a cap issue and you keep kicking
the can the reckoning is going to come
the question for the steelers is do they
take the reckoning now or do they take
the reckoning next year and you could
argue we'd better take the reckoning
next year when the salary caps higher
and without knowing the salary cap
that's the other part of this and this
is complicating negotiations throughout
the nfl if we don't know what the cap is
we don't know how much money to budget
to this guy this guy this guy this guy
how much of a pay cut do we ask ben
to take we don't know yet and that's the
broader dilemma the steelers are facing
the challenge is
how are we going to sprinkle a team
around him when we don't know what the
caps going to be and clark hunt the
chiefs
owner and finance committee chairman
suggested a couple of weeks ago miles
that they may not know until a few hours
before the league year begins it's a lot
of work that needs to be done in a short
period of time especially with
roethlisberger due to make a 15 million
roster bonus on the third day of the
league year so they may just decide
there's more work here than we can do
and even when we know the salary cap
we're not going to be able to get to
where we want to go so we're just going
to
throw our hands in the air and say we
have to pay for the sins of salary caps
passed
but that's not it just doesn't seem like
it would be the steelers way of doing
things for them to sort of throw their
hands up in the air because if there
were ever a year that they probably
should have done that it was 2019 when
ben got hurt so early on in the season
and then you gotta play mason play mason
rudolph and then they go out and they
get minka fitzpatrick and they trade
their first round pick and then they
still end up going 500 and so
i just don't necessarily see them doing
that and approaching it that way just
because it doesn't seem like the way the
steelers would ever do things however i
think in a year where you don't know
what the cap is going to be but you know
the cap is going down this also would be
the year that you say all right look
we're just gonna you know pay for the
sins of salary cap passed and contracts
passed and we're gonna just take the
reckoning now and then as we go into
2022 then we have a bit more of a fresh
start and then mike we can say oh this
is where we know we're going to go and
we know that we can plan to have a
better future if we just have this one
year where we may be a little bit down
and i'm i don't mean to suggest that
mike tomlin would throw his hands in the
air because he definitely didn't and i
think his his will and his force of
nature put them in a position where they
were an unlikely playoff contender in
2019 after losing big ben in week two
and they did make the minka fitzpatrick
trade but i think that's a trade they
make no matter what because that's the
guy they had their eyes on and the
opportunity was there and they were able
to grab him and he's one of those guys
where in hindsight you say man he should
have been a stealer from the get-go but
even if they say this is the year we
have to move on from ben and we're going
to let mason rudolph and dwayne haskins
compete and who knows what you're going
to have with wayne haskins maybe dwayne
haskins failed in washington because
washington right he was there
as a rookie
in the last year of bruce allen
dysfunction
so maybe if you give him a fresh start
somewhere else and he's been humbled by
what's happened in washington
maybe maybe he grows into somebody that
they can work with and turn into a
decent quarterback and then it's an
absolute steal you got a guy who was a
15th overall pick in the draft and you
know a lot of people criticized
washington
when they released him like oh god why'd
you take him if if they hadn't somebody
else was going to take him in round one
he was a round one talent this wasn't
one of those scratch your head what are
they doing they're pulling some guy out
of out of thin air this is a guy that
was regarded as a first-round prospect
so
hey it's it's only a positive whatever
you get out of him and if it doesn't
work out it's a low cost see you later
thanks for coming in and trying to play
so i i just
i i've been in and around pittsburgh
most of my life and i don't recall a
time
that there's been this kind of awkward
bizarre uncertainty with the steelers
and you know
there's a lesson to be learned i think
from
the
terry bradshaw departure there's a story
that tony dungy tells about the 83
steelers
when
they had dan marino
fall right into their laps in the draft
there he was
and they decided they didn't want to
have an awkward transition
and they didn't want to have issues with
mourinho on the roster and bradshaw on
the roster
and bradshaw gets injured that year and
that's his last season in the nfl and
they could have had marina they could
have had him period that was that and
and so
look there aren't a lot of people there
who were there
back in 1983 but art rooney art rooney
knows our rooney lived it our rooney was
part of the you know he was around the
family owned the team then and i i think
that you know the last time they they
they were overly patient with the
franchise quarterback it blew up in
their faces and i think they may be
they may be wondering
you know
given where we draft we're not all the
way at the bottom we made the playoffs
where i don't know what their draft
position is right now but my guess is
somewhere in the in the low 20s
maybe somebody falls into their lap and
if you have ben roethlisberger and
you've reconfigured the salary cap to
keep him around it makes it harder
to draft a quarterback you still can
packers did it last year but i i i just
i i think that
that one more year idea
i i just they're gonna regret it if they
do it
the team and or roethlisberger when we
get to november or december are gonna
say man we do we just shouldn't have
done this one more year especially if
they don't think they're a contender
it's one thing for jerome bettis to come
back one more year in 2005 when you got
a super bowl team and they won it
but when you when you aren't sure that
you can contend at a high level why hold
it together with ben for one more year
and by the way they have the 24th
overall pick so who knows what
quarterback will be there and they're
probably so early in their scouting
although they've got a decent amount of
hay in the barn at this point they
probably have a pretty good idea from
studying film who they may like but they
don't know who's going to be there it's
just it's a complicated situation for
the steelers but i think the worst thing
they could do is keep ben
he gets injured or they just they just
aren't very good this year and our final
memory of ben rothersberger with the
steelers is a a six and 10 team
i think the interesting thing about it
is
father time is undefeated and the only
person the father time hasn't defeated
is tom brady
yeah and like everybody else you know we
just we've seen it with drew brees
philip rivers you know peyton manning
all these quarterbacks who were of that
generation eli manning i guess we can
put in this category too where father
time just catches up and it seemed like
it was catching up to ben roethlisberger
and you know when we saw him on the
bench at the end of that playoff game
and he had tears in his eyes it just
seemed like maybe this is the end for
him but then he says he wants to come
back and so maybe this is like that last
year that that last time you know one
more ride that he can go out and try to
go out with a lombardi trophy and i just
i agree with him like i don't know that
they really are super bowl contenders at
this point and so because of that is it
really worth the one more year the one
last shot the one last ride i don't know
but
if roethlisberger still thinks he can
play at a high level it's probably hard
for the competitor in him to then say
well why would i not do this i still
love playing football i still love going
out there and competing with my
teammates i still love trying to throw
the ball down the field guys like chase
claypool i if i'm him i understand it
from that perspective but at the same
time i i think you're right with the
steelers man you you just don't want to
hang on too long when
there could be an opportunity to move on
and figure out who your next quarterback
is going to be for the next 10 15 years
that that's something that really is
important for any franchise mike
it's always hard to do the math in
february when there's 28 days in the
month but
i think he's 12 days away from turning
39 12 days away on march 2 ben
roethlisberger is 39. i wonder at some
level whether or not the things he's
saying about wanting to play is just
bravado and deep down he's
maybe hoping thinking wondering
that they'll decide to move on that he
doesn't want
to say
i retire i quit i whatever and and
that's the other side of it that would
be interesting and if he truly loves the
game and if he truly wants to keep
playing and they would cut him he's a
free agent
he'd go anywhere
and and think of it from that
perspective as we map out all of the
available options if ben roethlisberger
would be cut by the steelers today
is there a rush
for his services do the colts suddenly
say to the eagles you can take your
carson wentz trade demands and stick
them where the sun don't shine we're
going after ben roethlisberger
do the saints say well forget about
jameis winston take some hill we're
going after ben roethlisberger i don't
think so miles i'm trying to be
objective here
would there be do you think there would
be
a list of teams that would suddenly say
scratch out plan b plan c plan d our new
plan a is ben roethlisberger
i don't know that there would be a very
long list of teams but i think the the
colts would probably kick the tires on
it just because
he's a veteran guy they seem to be a
super bowl caliber team if they have the
right quarterback there i mean philip
rivers played decently well i thought
over the course of the season i thought
he got better as things went on um but
washington would be another team that i
might think okay if they have a qb that
can get things done
then yeah they're probably in a good
spot at competing especially because
they're in that lowly nfc east but if
i'm the saints i don't know why i would
want ben roethlisberger over somebody
like jameis winston i mean because look
jameis winston we know can throw the
ball we know can throw touchdowns his
only thing is can you cut down on the
turnovers and i think with sean payton
there yeah
they probably have a better shot with
him especially because he's been in that
system already for a year than getting
somebody like a ben roethlisberger and
trying to roll the dice just one last
time on that they already went through
that with drew brees this year i think
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports